we can do an investment prior to a
validation of the technology so we will
start with the poc
and then see um that we're fascinated
about the technology and we see a like a
very
disruptive approach
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders hey thank you for having
me
so great to have you here are you
calling from tel aviv right now
no i actually i'm calling from kyrie
tonight where i live
uh now but uh previously i lived for
many years in
tel aviv and prior to that in jerusalem
and prior to that
in new york i was actually born in new
york amazing khadar you have
a very unique job and which i think most
entrepreneurs and most
people around me aren't even aware that
exists
especially in the industry that you're
in what is the title
that you that you hold within porsche
so i work at a subsidiary of porsche
called porsche digital
and i'm a director there and leading the
activities the innovation activities and
scouting
in israel so leading the innovation and
scouting activities in israel for
one of the most successful automobile
companies in the world the subsidiary of
it
that is intended for ventures for
innovation
and and creation why does
a car manufacturing company luxury car
company need
an arm of innovation and ventures
um so i i'm sure that all of your
viewers are aware that israel is
not a startup nation but now he's
becoming a scale-up nation and a lot of
the technologies that are super
relevant not only for an organization as
an organization but also as a mobility
player
or a tech giant uh are coming from
israel so a lot of machines that are
planning
nation and startup nation by the way so
you're not familiar i i need to know
okay so there's a shift in the mindset
of
of now leaders and uh and investors and
entrepreneurs in israel trying to
not just promote israeli founders to
start companies and
sell them relatively quickly but rather
to
expand them and not to sell them as fast
as they can but
to build big big successful companies so
i i am
personally very like in favor of this
shift
a paradigm shift and i hope that we'll
see more and more companies uh
scaling in israel and not uh selling too
faster companies
so just for context forever doesn't
doesn't understand you know so we had
the startup nation this wonderful
miraculous idea of
of israel this tiny hub of of creativity
and innovation by
force people are people are forced to be
innovative and creative from a very
young age
and generally attributed to the army and
then we received some critics
some criticism as the exit nation
because we developed the amazing
technologies
seldom short instead of trying to grow
them but recently we've seen some
incredible
innovators like fiverr lemonade wix
eye um and so many more a trade factions
party that are now unicorns and ways of
course
uh and so scale up nation okay now back
to porsche
yeah so we opened our facility
officially in 2018 prior to that our
leadership basically came and was
starting to develop a
a very big interest toward the israeli
market and like
the innovation coming from here and one
thing led to another and they
eventually decided that they need the
permanent people here an official
office and and somebody that will pursue
uh only this activity
uh i was lucky enough and privileged
enough
to be introduced to porsche via grove
which is a
prominent vc in israel and basically
yeah so uh porsche invested in growth
prior to
to me and my colleagues really i didn't
know yeah and they were looking for a
person in ezra and we were connected
i was quite hesitant why portia is
reaching out to me
i had actually an interview at my my
former
office at deloitte basically met with
them didn't know what they want but was
truly excited about their idea of
developing something in israel and
seeking israeli innovation and with the
hopes of deploying it
and yeah so one thing led to another i
joined in late 2018
uh basically our office has two core
activities one is
uh tech scouting not just for the sake
of doing projects or pocs but
for the the sake of deployment um so
we the rangers when you think of
deployment what does that mean does it
actually mean
integrating technology within the cars
themselves absolutely so this is this is
one but also in the on the enterprise
level and
our production uh we seek to see
technologies being integrated into our
facilities
into our computers into everything um
so we uh work together with our
colleagues at
uh crochet ag the parent company uh
in vice saftvi where the r d center in
stuttgart and we
basically try to analyze potential
companies we have
basically a dual methodology of scouting
both a pull and a push so the most
preferred ways
is to get companies to get a specific
request from a business unit to really
understand a specific need
and then to go and analyze the most
relevant
companies and to bring them to the table
and potentially
do a poc and once the pocs this is like
a top-down approach where you have a
business unit within porsche
that says hey we have this problem can
we do some scouting and see if there's
any interesting
early middle or late stage startups
perhaps in israel
that are working in this space and then
we can approach them proactively
and try to get some sort of
collaboration that's that's the way that
you are
referring to yeah so this is the primary
way where we
see a very high conversion rate because
it inherently we'll we will have a
business unit we'll have a project lead
the budget and everything
but definitely we are extremely
proactive in trying to advocate
new companies or new business models
that are particularly interesting for a
specific unit
and sometimes a unit cannot really
articulate articulate themselves okay
we acknowledge these technologies
sometimes they will not be aware of what
exactly is in the market and and this is
why we also focus on
meeting constantly with companies and
with vcs and with
major stakeholders and trying to uh be
ahead of the game
uh basically so this is one arm we've
conducted in 2019 over
10 pocs we deployed several technologies
uh 2020 had a rocky start with covey but
we were
thankful to conduct uh
various pocs and deployments and uh
yeah so we're working hard it's a small
team but
we're trying to do a lot i mean remember
the whole investment side right where
you're
actually a venture arm that is making
active investments in companies
so basically uh porsche ventures
is the the cbc the strategic
investor arm of porsche we
invest in four different locations
around the
globe in the us germany china and ezra
my colleague talia is more focusing on
the investment side i'm on the tech
scouting but obviously we do everything
together so companies
what sorry
i'm doing the tech scouting so yeah yeah
and innovation doing all of the projects
but it goes
hand in hand because every investment we
can do an investment prior to
a validation of the technology so we
will start with a poc and then
see um that we're fascinated about the
technology and we see a
like a very disruptive approach and then
we will
potentially proceed to to analyzing a
potential investment
so you will and you will only invest
then in companies that are
specifically relevant to your domain
your expertise and
technologies that you can validate as
porsche right
so definitely we are always looking how
to push the boundaries and do
new new types of mobility and do things
that are
not just within the car um but
definitely
we have our our core activity but uh
there are new
uh topics and new things that we're
looking at so constantly looking
and trying to innovate also within the
topics that are
relevant for us okay so so talk to me a
little bit about about how you got into
this
it's not that ordinary to uh to meet
somebody who's working on the venture
and innovation arm
of a car manufacturing company a leading
one
especially at that porsche and so it's
it's a very very cool job but
but i'd love to know who holds that job
so
deloitte itt a lawyer for many years
and who are you
uh it's a tough question i don't know
i'm not only my
job roles but i think i'm a person has a
lot of
other uh i don't know passions and
interests but
uh i don't know where do you want me to
start from i want to start from the
passions
what are you actually passionate about
so you've got you you did
you did a lot of a lot you have a lot of
background in the tech space now from a
lot of different
point angles coming into it what are you
really really excited about
um basically pushing innovation and
trying to
um help big companies
succeed through uh collaboration with
startups so obviously i'm a big
passionate
big ambassador of the israeli startup
nation and
uh trying to support israeli companies
and founders
uh but also wants to try to help
big corporations understand and
acknowledge that they can't solve
everything internally they need to
utilize external
technologies to solve big problems and
to to make
a big impact um so yeah passionate about
impact and help the itt was the idt
sort of being an ambassador and
representative of the startup nation
so it's a good question so it's my time
it was
called the innovation tech terminal and
now it is
rebranded as a deloitte catalyst so
me and uh my former uh colleague amit al
basically joined forces to establish
this
new uh startup activity of the deloitte
us and israel
with the main aspiration of helping
deloitte's largest clients to
tap into the israeli ecosystem and try
to
find not only the best companies but
the right way to solve business issues
through
investments acquisitions and deployments
and we've done quite similarly to what i
do now
activities with the deloitte's largest
clients and we hosted c-suite of
of fortune 100 and we were divided the
art
our team was divided into pro like
sectors so
people and one guy was the domain
manager in terms of mobility and fintech
and retail
and healthcare and we had a lot of very
talented
team members that were focusing on each
domain and we basically
helped a really big clients understand
how they can
uh utilize exactly these the israeli
tech
to to solve their uh biggest issues
and through i think the two and a half
years uh that of my 10 years there we
were uh
privileged to do to execute more than uh
80 global projects we
i think helped multinationals realize
that they're not
only interested in deploying a certain
technology or potentially investing in a
company but rather opening an r d
center or an innovation hub in israel so
companies like td bank and others uh
were good examples and
yeah it was a great great time and and
it got
it helped me to realize how uh
fascinating this job could be at the
time i was a service provider
essentially so i was not making calling
the shots right but i was helping
i was trying our our team was trying to
uh
support these decision makers in in
taking
big changes and shifting mindsets and
and helping them
uh solve their biggest issues through
israeli technologies
i love it i love it and so talk to me a
little bit about this
and the the some of the struggles of a
of a large corporation
to go and integrate uh you know pocs and
software from from early
or middle stage start so one of the
things you mentioned that you're that
you're
very excited about is helping large
enterprises realize the potential of the
outside ecosystem
and in sort of amending
some of the things that the company
wants or needs right so instead of
developing internally going to see okay
is there maybe a startup that can help
us do that
and make that connection what are some
of the difficulties or some of the
opportunities that you're seeing
within that realm so
the difficulties i think are quite
obvious so
organizations work much much much slower
um in comparison to startups that
every day it's a roller coaster so in
one month you can
you can pivot twice you can raise up a
lot of funds you can
expand the team or decrease the amount
of the team that i have to ease by by
i don't know what and basically startups
can't really
afford to have uh two months of
execution of an nda prior to even
seriously discussing a potential
collaboration right so i think one of
a big issue is to or not issue but
one of our roles is to try to expedite
processes
uh to try to help an organization
understand that the they need to be a
bit more agile
in their minds how does that happen
actually though do you actually go so do
you go to the
senior vice president and say listen
you're now you're not dealing with a
startup it's not another
business like get moving or how do you
actually explain the process for this
yeah so it's quite delicate because we
can't be super super duper israeli we
can't push it
after meeting maybe 10 emails because
they would not be very appreciative of
that
but we definitely try to uh
do it to to get uh things done as fast
as we can
to be very uh i don't know um supportive
and
and and respective of the time of a
company that uh
startup that cannot afford too much time
and this is one major
issue a lot of other things are cultural
differences you know sometimes the
israelis are
very upfront and then and there are
other things that say
and not every organization or or
type of people is confrontationalized
israelis and there are a lot of other
differences that we try to
mitigate or try to you know bridge um
there are a bunch of other topics i
don't know uh i'm sure i don't know i
think
you know i think it's just fascinating
just you know considering this and i
think what's really fascinating that
we're we're headed and i'm seeing this
constantly here this idea
that uh you know the world is changing
so so fast
a lot of these businesses uh you know
you can look at covet coming in
and a great example is my one of my best
friends
has a startup in tel aviv coveted and
he's in the travel space covet hit
basically crushed his business had to
you know
forego a third to a half of his
employees and he was able to pivot
within 24 hours and go to a whole new
route
and he actually built something that
over a quarter of a million people use
right now to help decide where to travel
on the same note you have largest mickey
your friend ah
mickey okay there you go israel
we know everybody um
so and on the other hand you have large
corporations
which are getting covered and now they
have to decide how long do we wait until
we make that pivot
how much are we how much are we
considering this how much pivoting can
we do
once we've already settled down and we
have this core business opportunity and
if we want to pivot
can we do it fast enough internally or
do we want to utilize a startup outside
to do that
so i think it's all really fascinating
questions because i think covet was just
an example of
of of circumstances that are going to
cause huge consumer shifts
and market shifts and we're just getting
you know the knock on the head of okay
maybe maybe we have to be a little bit
more agile as a world than than we were
before
i don't know i can't believe 20 minutes
are almost done but it also apparently
are you real i have to ask the most
important question
i need three words that you would best
describe yourself
or that any of your colleagues or any of
the startups you invested in they would
describe a dar
so it's hard because i don't like
talking too much about myself and i like
to give uh
i don't know just for the record i'm
forcing you to say this this is not your
choice
okay okay so i'll do it i think the
first
word would be uh so i try to get you
done i'm very pragmatic
and trying to push stuff forward uh
second thing i think it correlates to
what i said before so i'm very
passionate whether it's uh
with respect to my work to israel to
innovation to
helping people stuff like that uh maybe
ile could say some words about that
um and the third word would be uh
connector
so through my job and also on my um just
time off i'd like to not only connect
internally with people but connect with
other people and just connections
and then people uh something that i do
on a
on a daily basis yeah i love it
thank you and i look forward to meeting
in israel after this whole corona thing
is over definitely
yeah wonderful okay bye thank you so
much
you